اشباه الموصلات او الرقائق الالكترونيه
اساسيه في كل المجالات من صناعه السيارات
والنقل الى قطاع الطاقه
وتلعب هذه الرقائق دورا مركزيا في
الصناعات العسكريه المتقدمه
فبفضلها يتعرف صاروخ جافل على هدفه ويصيبه
بدقه قاتله
الرقائق الالكترونيه الانواع ولكنها في
الاساسي شرائح تصنع من ماده النصف موصله
كالسيليكون وتتكون من عده الاف من
الترانزستورات تسمح بتدفق التيار
الكهربائي في اتجاه واحد
وتبرمج كل شريحه بشكل يسمح لها باداء
مهامها حسب القطاع الصناعي الذي تصنع
لاجله الصين تريد ان تصبح اكبر مصنع
لاشباه الموصلات في العالم الامر الذي
يدفع امريكا الى محاوله كسر طموح بكين
بتشجيع اقطاب التكنولوجيا الامريكيه على
تصنيعها محليا اضافه الى فرضها عقوبات على
شركات صينيه في هذا المجال
هنا لتخفيض التكلفه ولخلق وظائف مجزئه
لامريكي
ما يقلق واشنطن كذلك هو الوتيره المتصاعده
لبرنامج التسليح الصيني الذي يسعى لتطوير
القدرات العسكريه النوويه اضافه الى
رغبتها في امتلاك اسلحه فرط صوتيه لا
تستطيع الدفاعات المضاده للصواريخ الغربيه
الحاليه التصدي لها كصاروخي دي اف 17
البالستي الفرط صوتي
ما يزيد الوضع والترا بين القوتين هو ان
شركه تي اس ام سي التايوانيه تصنع الرقائق
المستخدمه في تصنيع الاسلحه الامريكيه
كمقاتله اف 35 ذات القدرات القتاليه
المتقدمه ما يعني ان سقوط تايوان في يد
الصين او تدمير هذه الاخيره
للقدرات التصنيعيه الخاصه بالرقائق ستكون
ضربه قاسيه للصناعه العسكريه
ما سيؤدي الى تراجع تاثير واشنطن على
الساحه الدوليه
حرب تكنولوجيه وسباق لامتلاك اكثر الاسلحه
تطورا قد تنزلق الى مواجهه مباشره خاصه مع
حالات التوتر الكبير الذي يشوب الوضع
الدولي العربيه